seit vier uhr nachts ist er auf den
beinen was für andere harte arbeit wäre
ist für bäckermeister kasten berning
fast schon erholung
denn in den frühen morgenstunden kann
endlich mal das machen was er liebt
backen kein handyempfang
da gibt es nur ein einfaches telefon und
nachts ist sowieso am wenigsten los da
da braucht man nicht ständig erreichbar
zu sein aber um acht ist schluss mit
backen berning hat fünf filialen und
beliefert große kunden kunden
lieferanten mitarbeiter eines der drei
telefone klingelt immer und dann geht's
halt einfach nur 3 nach doch das fällt
ihm immer schwerer
denn die neuen technologien schaffen
ständig neue aufgaben etwa die
aktualisierung von internetseiten oder
facebook auftritten auch berning wirbt
auf allen kanälen die großen
billigketten sitzen im handwerksbetrieb
im nacken
zwischendurch schnell zum arzt der
rücken schmerzt ein stress im turm erst
den handy knopf ins ohr den so lassen
sich unterwegs noch bestellungen machen
ständiges multitasking bisher unfallfrei
die wartezeit beim orthopäden nutzt der
38 jährige ebenfalls das smartphone
macht's möglich
er erwartet berning so viel einsatz auch
von seinen mitarbeitern definitiv nicht
also ich kann nicht von meinen
angestellten erwarten dass sie immer und
jederzeit zu erreichen sind dass das
geht nicht das hält ja keine auf dauer
aus wer derart für die arbeit brennt ist
irgendwann womöglich ausgebrannt kommen
noch berufliche oder private fehlschläge
dazu wird es gefährlich psychiater wie
master art nie verordnen dann erst
einmal eine zwangspause
diese veränderung wie es letzte bieli
sierung der der arbeitsplätze
digitalisierung im beruf ständige
erreichbarkeit keine trennung zwischen
berufsleben und privatleben sind
risikofaktoren die zu mehr stress führen
können und das kann wiederum einen burn
out prozess begünstigen die
krankenkassen schlagen alarm immer mehr
krankmeldungen wegen stress
stressbedingte krankheiten kosten die
unternehmen in deutschland in europa
enorm viel geld man rechnet mit 20
milliarden euro jährlich allein in der
bundesrepublik
carsten berning sieht sich noch nicht
gefährdet
dazu werden morgen noch eine
hochzeitstorte reinbekommen und so eine
erdbeertorte werden denn er macht das
was er tut gerne
nach feierabend dann entspannung im
garten
allerdings auch hier her nimmt er sich
gerne mal arbeit mit auch an den
wochenenden
ja das ist es kommt manchmal vorwänden
hat irgendwelche großprojekte sind zum
beispiel dass nur das computer system
eingeführt wird neue kassen eingeführt
werden wo man eine menge
vorbereitungsarbeit machen muss was man
in der woche gar nicht so schafft weil
halt einfach der der der tägliche stress
die tägliche arbeit zu groß ist dass ich
dann mir das halt auch mal ins
wochenende mitnehmen und das mache ich
versuche wie im garten findet er trotz
laptop ein wenig ruhe
morgen früh um vier geht das rennen dann
weiter